9:00 p.m. Friday evening
the weekends just beginning in Portland
Oregon but it's no party at the
Multnomah County Detention Center the
officers here are on the front lines
keeping dangerous criminals off the
street when's the last time you shot
everybody arrested in the city of
Portland tonight we'll end up here to be
booked whether they like it or not four
deputies that means facing off with
arrestees who may be angry and
aggressive like this young woman who
allegedly assaulted her boyfriend and
some total strangers during a drinking
binge
the officers challenge get every
arrestee under control a hazardous job
on so many offenders and not just
violent but drug-addicted
and mentally ill deputy Bledsoe is a
12-year veteran who often mans the book
encounter the first stop for intake and
processing for all arrestees Bludso's
learn to expect anything oh no every
night's different you can't predict it's
beginning to shift how the night's gonna
go I mean we could uses of force it
could be a quiet night we have no
problems and then sometimes we have to
fill all these cells up back here blood
so we'll routinely see a hundred
individuals pass through here on a
single day this County Jail is one of
the busiest in the country booking
45,000 people a year blood so when the
other deputies need to be on constant
alert since all the arrestees wait for
their mugshots and further processing in
a big open space
it's like any other waiting room except
it's filled with people accused of
everything from drunk driving to
disorderly conduct to theft and assault
surprisingly they're not cuffed or
restrained in any way it's part of a
policy intended to help reduce stress
during booking but over two-thirds of
the arrestees are drug users and many
are high on crystal meth a drug that can
produce psychotic outbursts one of them
could blow at any time an attack an
officer shifts sergeant Gordon knows all
too well the ultimate challenge for us
is maintaining a certain level of safety
and security because we don't have cages
to put these people in they're out in
the open they're out in an area where
anything can happen at any time
sergeant Gordon and the deputies always
go unarmed
that way no weapon ever gets into the
wrong hands so all they have to protect
themselves other wits and a zero
tolerance for any kind of resistance
it's what keeps them safe from harm you
understand okay I give up I give up
when people come to jail when they get
arrested they're mad when they come to
jail they're angrier and then when they
come in here and we start invading their
close personal space they get even more
angry that booking counter is probably
one of the most volatile places in the
facility when it comes to physical
encounters with an inmate